يبدو ان كلمات الرئيس الصيني حين كان يقف
امام نظيره الروسي اربكت صوره القطب
الواحد التي تستقتل الولايات المتحده
للحفاظ عليها حين قال ان يوافقه بوتا سريع
اليوم تنشر صحيفه وستري جونل تقريرا يشير
الى دخول الجيش الامريكي حقبه جديده من
منافسه القوى العظمى روسيا والصين ضمن
استراتيجيه 2014 الشامله تجاه اسيا تخطط
الولايات المتحده لنشر طائرات هجوميه
متقادمه من طراز اي 10 في الشرق الاوسط
كبديل لمقاتلات اكثر تطورا تنقلها الى
المحيط الهادئ واوروبا ابريل القادم
المسؤولون الامريكيون ذكروا للصحيفه ان
تقارير تخلص الى انه لا توجد طائرات
مقاتله كافيه لمواجهه التحدي الصيني
المتزايد والعدوان الروسي كما سموه بموجب
الخطه الجديده سيتمركز سرب من طائرات اي
10 في المنطقه الى جانب سربين من طائرات
اف 15 اي واف سته عشر بمعدل حوالي 12
طائره للسرب
في السابق لقد خطوه القوات الجويه بالتخلص
التدريجي من طائرات اي 10 وصيانتها لتوفير
الاموال لبرامج اخرى مقاومه كبيره من
الكونجرس فبالنسبه للطائره التي يبلغ
عمرها 14 عقود قد يكون اداؤها محرجا امام
مواجهه مع طائرات صينيه من الجيل الحديث
اننا نتقاعد من طائرات اي 10 اسرع مما كنا
نعتقد لن تكون الموازنه بين الشرق الاوسط
والاقصى عمليه سهله لكنها ضروريه وعاجله
فهي اولا وكما تراها واشنطن مساله تهديد
لقواتها ومصالحها غير ان متقاعدين من
الجويه الامريكيه ذكروا للصحيفه ان نشر
طائرات ضعيفه في المنطقه سيقوض من قدره
الجيش الامريكي وصموده امام خطر مستقبلي
لم يحسب له حساب في قرار اليوم كرم حناوي
العربيه